c'est très symbolique quand on passe ce
portail pour les coupés du monde là
vraiment une réalité concrète et chose
pour fait de faire un projet là dessus
sont vraiment impliqués
c'est important de savoir ce qui s'est
passé avant pas que ça se reproduise il
faut se rappeler ce qu ils ont vécu non
pas les oublier au final au lycée
charles de gaulle ce matin là près d'une
centaine d'élèves de 1re et de 3e
étaient réunis pour écouter le récit de
marcel dressler et je voulais vous
parler de la famille de mes grands
parents qui sont d'ailleurs morts
disparus assassinés à 88 ans elle
accepte de témoigner mais refuse d'être
filmé l'antisémitisme continue à lui
faire peur né en france dans une famille
polonaise de confession juive elle
n'avait que 11 ans lorsqu'elle a échappé
à la déportation
il y avait beaucoup de gens qui est
arrêté et nous on était en état de
sidération en état de choc quand je
demandais bien ce qui se passait parce
que c'était très rapide on n'avait même
pas le temps de réagir qu'on était déjà
embarqué c'était très bien là arrêté
avec sa tante et son cousin elle seule a
été libéré parce qu'elle était française
toujours à s'agenouiller l'embrasser
puis les portes
bon je vais je pensais pas que j'allais
jamais la revoir
vous savez dans ces conditions là on
passe de l'enfance à l'âge adulte sans
passédat parle par l'adolescence qui est
le plus émouvant c'est de se dire c'est
se dire que les images que nous
transmettent ils les ondes et les
reprendre en tête alors que nous on
essaie d'imaginer on se forme des images
c'est les personnes qui pourront plus
témoigner dans quelques temps donc c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut prendre comme
eux peut-être la dernière fois qu'elle
témoigne donc il faut être là il faut
écouter second témoignage à celui des
collettes morgan besser présente mais
c'est sa petite fille qui raconte pour
elle son histoire enfant abandonné par
sa mère juive polonaise
elle a été confiée par l'assistance
publique à pierrette pech art une
paysanne du morvan qui a hébergé et
sauvé quatre autres enfants juifs frères
et soeurs qui aujourd'hui vivent aux
états unis
pire est à l'ap a sauvé cinq enfants au
jour d'aujourd'hui à la sauver
vingt-cinq personnes puisque pierre est
alors déjà nous sommes trois de ce côté
là puisque j'ai une maman aussi et en
sauvant ses quatre enfants qui sont
partis aux états unis ils ont chacun eu
des enfants des petits enfants
décédé en 2008 pierrette pochard est
devenue juste parmi les nations en 2012
sa médaille son diplôme sont exposées au
musée de la résistance de saint brisson
on utilise habite juste à côté de chez
nous on vous pourrez les connaître mais
mais c'est à dire qu'ils ont vécu
quelque chose comme ça c'est très
important et des villages qu'elle
incitait je suis déjà allé dans le
morvan plusieurs fois donc cdd lui que
je peux imaginer et imaginer l'époque
l'époque
enfin ces villages sont la guerre
vraiment oui je trouve ça important je
trouve que ça remet les choses dans leur
contexte aussi vous dit pas c'est
quelque chose qui était loin en
allemagne où l'urss s'était c'est aussi
ici c'était aussi la résistance des
hommes et des femmes qui ont incarné des
valeurs d'humanité et de générosité et
de tolérance
message reçu cinq sur cinq par les
lycéens quand on lit leurs mots et tout
ça ça nous fait une centaine ça nous
permet de faire une synthèse à nous
aussi pour améliorer les choses pour
voir sur quels points d'insister plus ou
moins etc
mais quelque part on comprend en lisant
leurs messages voilà le mot humanitaire
sort certains deux fois tolérance des
terrasses ça veut dire qu'on avait on à
atteindre notre objectif qui était des
touchés et il leur fera comprendre ces
notions qui sont ont été celles des
justes au 1er novembre 2018 4082 juste
été reconnue en france dont 120 en
bourgogne